again you watching cable eat breakfast
11 people who didn't make it onto last
week's evacuation flight from China's
coronavirus epicenter have now arrived
back in the UK the group made up of
British nationals and family members
joined the 83 people already quarantined
in staff accommodation in arrow Park
Hospital on the well let's talk about it
in more detail awaiting them over the
next 14 days what could that be in
quarantine joined by khan lambert who
was part of the group evacuated from
Wuhan on Friday he's been in isolation
since then hello - you can't thanks for
joining us what's it like in isolation
it's very strange
it's it's quite weird being home but not
being home and also being solved locked
in almost by like being back in Wuhan
really where we can't really get outside
certain perimeters and and and and go
further so it's a bit of a weird feeling
really others arrived last night I think
didn't they you like to interact with
them communicate with them yeah they
arrived around midnight last night and
we haven't seen them yet and I'm not
entirely sure what their processes are
what the protocol is on having contact
with them I do believe that they have
been put into a separate area in the
building but again we've had no
information on that yet and I'm pretty
sure that we'll receive that information
today I wonder how you managing to
entertain yourselves during the like two
weeks of isolation I read somewhere that
the Playstations and Barbie dolls were
being shipped in yeah we have a lot of
very wonderful people in the world who
are donating kids toys who are donating
things to keep us entertained books
playing cards and yeah we do have some
Playstations and it boxes here but most
of this stuff is coming from donations
from people on the world just to try and
keep us entertained really yeah I think
grandmas with you isn't she she is yeah
I should do in she's okay the troubling
you know they're 40 under our trampoline
or 30 on our travelling wiped her out a
little bit so she's been in a room
the last couple of days trying to catch
up on some sleep and them and sort of
come back to you know back to reality
really but I spoke to her late last
night before I went to bed and she was
she's in good spirits again now
glad to hear it what happens when this
is all over we don't have any
information on that again I'm pretty
sure that they will give us that
information closer to the time of being
released from this facility but I'm sure
that it will be you know go home try to
sort of get some good rest and and then
obviously plan for the future you know
nobody knows where exactly what will
happen beyond leaving here in terms of
sort of going back to China etc would
you go back to Wuhan do you think I
probably will yeah you know I have a job
over there so it's not easy just to sort
of up and leave the job so I probably
will but obviously I will follow the
advice of I would government of Anna
will follow the advice of the Chinese
government and I will follow the
situation closely as to when and and
what time I'll go back in the meantime
you being well cared for here back in
the United Kingdom what about a staff
who were there who were looking after
you I mean are they do they have any
protection on their faces or are they
just chatting to you normally what how's
that work yeah they're all being told to
wear protection ie masks and gloves when
they're in the communal areas they do
have their own sort of office where
we're not allowed and that don't allows
them to take off their equipment and and
sort of get you know breathe normally
and cetera but they've been absolutely
fantastic since the moment we arrived
you know and we can't thank them enough
for everything that they're doing for us
at the moment
indeed so and as you say grandma is
doing okay what about some of the others
that the 80 or so others that came over
with you from Wuhan at the end of last
week everyone fits and well just bored
and ready to go home I'm guessing yeah
everybody is in good spirits you know as
you can imagine it's not the best of
circumstances but you know we're all
trying to keep each other's spirits high
you know we're playing jokes on each
other we're having a laugh
when we have the chance to see each
other you know last night we played some
cards and we had a few be able to laugh
but you know nobody's showing any
symptoms nobody's complaining of any
illnesses at the moment which is good
and fingers crossed that that will
continue to be this case up until the
day where we get to leave this place
okay well you look after yourself I'm
glad to hear that sir your Nan's doing
alright I know that she has the
respiratory issues doesn't she and you
were very worried about her at the time
but it sounds as though everything's
proceeding normally again now so glad to
hear that can and you look after
yourself as well thanks so much indeed
for continue to update as we appreciate
it thank you